Elon musk's new rocket exploded after
successfully lifting off again nobody
expected the thing to make it all the
way to Mars on the first go either way
it was meant to crash land the only
question was how far it would get before
it was destroyed ultimately it made it
20 miles into space which is pretty
damned impressive for a vessel the size
of a 40-story building it also means
that they were able to gather important
information it'll make the next launch
even more successful you have to walk
before you can run you have to get your
rocket twice the size of a Boeing triple
seven into into the stratosphere before
you can get into outer space this is
what science and Discovery are supposed
to look like this is how they work
Innovation is a series of failures as
long as you learn from them the process
is working exactly as it should you
can't achieve anything worthwhile
without taking risks and if you take
risks you're guaranteed to fail at least
some of the time anybody who takes risks
and never fails isn't really taking
risks at all this is what separates Risk
Takers from everybody else the risk
taker has the courage to fail